Hundebesitzer leben länger.
Selbstzweifler dafür kürzer.
Ältere Väter haben nerdigere Söhne
und optische Täuschungen
verbessern die Sehkraft.
Damit herzlich willkommen
bei Science News!
* Musik *
Freunde der Sonne, setzt euch,
wir haben keine Zeit zu verlieren.
In der Wissenschaft
passieren so viele Dinge,
ich kann nicht
über alles extra Videos machen.
Deswegen hab ich 5 News aus der aktu-
ellen Forschung für euch. Let's go!
Nr. 1: geklonte Puppies.
Vielleicht erinnert sich ja jemand:
2005 wurde der erste geklonte Hund
der Welt geboren, Snuppy.
Leider verstarb Snuppy
im Alter von 10 Jahren,
genauso wie sein Vorgänger Tie,
an Krebs.
Aber kein Grund zur Traurigkeit,
denn Snuppy wurde wieder geklont,
und zwar direkt dreimal.
Wie das funktioniert? Ganz einfach:
Man nimmt eine Hunde-Eizelle,
nimmt da die DNA raus,
tut dafür Snuppy-Zellen rein,
die wurden ihm
im Alter von 5 Jahren entnommen,
und setzt dann die Embryonen
Hunde-Leihmüttern ein.
4 neue Snuppys
kamen letztes Jahr zur Welt,
die Ergebnisse
wurden diesen Monat veröffentlicht.
Ein Welpe
starb leider nach der Geburt.
Die anderen 3 erfreuen sich
derzeit bester Gesundheit
und sie werden
in den nächsten 10 Jahren
hoffentlich viele neue wissen-
schaftliche Erkenntnisse liefern
über das Klonen
und vielleicht sogar über Krebs.
Apropos Hunde, Nr. 2:
Hundebesitzer leben länger
und erkranken seltener
an Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen.
Besonders zahlt sich
ein Hund für Alleinlebende aus,
da liegt das Sterberisiko etwa
33 % niedriger als bei Hundelosen
und auch das Herzinfarkt-Risiko
ist 11 % niedriger.
So viel zur Korrelation. Was
die kausalen Zusammenhänge betrifft,
das gilt es jetzt herauszufinden.
Ist es die soziale Bindung
oder das tägliche Gassigehen
an der frischen Luft?
Weitere Forschung
wird es vielleicht zeigen.
Nr. 3: Menschen, die glauben, sich
weniger zu bewegen, sterben früher.
Was glaubst du? Bewegst du dich mehr
oder weniger als der Durchschnitt?
Dass Bewegungsmangel ungesund ist,
ist vielfach belegt.
Jetzt stellt sich heraus,
dass allein der Glaube daran,
sich zu wenig zu bewegen,
bereits ungesund ist.
Und das sogar unabhängig davon,
wie viel man sich tatsächlich bewegt.
Bei einer Untersuchung
von 60.000 Amerikanern zeigte sich,
dass diejenigen, die glaubten,
sich weniger zu bewegen
als der Durchschnitt,
ein höheres Sterberisiko hatten.
Ob eine negative Selbsteinschätzung
auch tatsächlich die Ursache
für ein kürzeres Leben ist,
das gilt es herauszufinden.
Jedenfalls erinnert das
an andere Studien, die herausfanden,
dass Menschen,
die sich selbst zu dick finden,
eher an Herz-Kreislauf-
Erkrankungen leiden;
auch, wenn sie Normalgewicht haben.
Nr. 4: Ältere Väter
haben nerdigere Söhne.
Wissenschaftler haben sich
selbst untersucht, nämlich Nerds,
und Nerdiness ist offenbar vererbbar.
Die Forscher quantifizierten die
Nerdiness anhand eines Geek-Index',
das denke ich mir nicht aus,
das steht genauso im Paper,
eines Geek-Index',
der sich an 3 Faktoren festmacht.
1. nonverbale Intelligenz,
2. starker Fokus
auf Spezialinteressen
und 3. äh, ja... ein distanziertes
soziales Verhalten.
Dabei fanden die Forscher heraus,
dass der Geek-Index
zu fast 60 % erblich bedingt ist
und dass die Geekiness oder Nerdiness
mit dem Alter des Vaters steigt.
Nr. 5: Ich zeige euch
eine optische Täuschung,
mit der ihr eure Sehkraft verbessern
könnt, wenn auch nur kurzzeitig.
Optische Täuschungen
tricksen unser Gehirn aus.
Wenn man z.B.
auf eine Spirale starrt,
die sich im Uhrzeigersinn dreht,
und danach was anderes anschaut,
dann sieht es so aus, als würden
die Dinge wachsen, größer werden.
Das testen wir gleich.
Denn was die Forscher herausgefunden
haben, ist verblüffend.
Sie zeigten Versuchsteilnehmern genau
das hier, und danach konnten diese
kleine Buchstaben
bei einem Sehtest besser entziffern.
Bisher ging man davon aus,
dass Sehkraft ausschließlich
etwas mit dem Zustand
unserer Augen zu tun hat.
Also dem physiologischen Zustand.
Diese Studie zeigt erstmals,
dass das Ganze auch etwas mit unserer
Wahrnehmung zu tun haben könnte.
Wie das Ganze aussieht?
Seid ihr bereit, es zu testen?
Schaut jetzt auf den Bildschirm!
* Ruhige Klaviermusik *
Uuund jetzt!
Und?
Werde ich immer größer?
Waaah!
Freunde der Sonne, das war
eine Auswahl aus aktueller Forschung.
Alle Paper habe
ich euch natürlich unten verlinkt.
Bin gerade dabei, ein paar
neue Formate auszutesten einfach.
D.h., wenn euch das hier gefallen
hat, lasst es mich irgendwie wissen,
macht euch irgendwie bemerkbar.
Wenn es gut ankommt,
mache ich das gerne auch noch mal.
Ansonsten wir sehen uns
nächste Woche, bleibt sicher!
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Ah, meine Nachbarn hämmern.
Wir haben keine Zeit,
wir sind bei Science News!